what's up guys so as you guys already
know GPU prices are out of the world
right now some cards are even double
their MSRP many new gamers and builders
looking to upgrade their pcs are very
angry and annoyed by the situation
however a new ray of hope has arise very
recently because nvidia may solve this
whole issue just next month that's right
there is a rumor floating around that
Nvidia will bring our graphics card or a
series of graphics cards they'll be
geared towards mining this will heavily
relieve the strain that miners are
imposing on their gaming GPU market and
this will lead to gaming GPUs to drop in
price this new gaming GPU is to be
called Turing and the reason that many
speculators predict that this will be a
mining GPU is due to its unique name
many believe that this GPU is named
after Alan Turing who is often referred
to as the father of modern and very
computing he was a mathematician
logician philosopher and theoretical
biologist but what sticks out about him
is that he was also a crypt analyst
this doesn't mean that he was a
cryptocurrency market analyst or
anything like that because
cryptocurrency didn't even exist during
his lifetime analysis it's actually
a field of study in which a person and
analyzes information systems in order to
study their hidden aspects of the system
however the possum IT itself is really
not that much different because it is
really just compiling recent
cryptocurrency transactions into blocks
for information systems and using that
information to attempt solving a
computationally difficult puzzle so both
those are quite similar plus companies
don't just choose random names for their
new products they have reason behind
them for example take a look at the
Nintendo switch the codename for this
device was Nintendo NX I believe that
the extras signaling that the the switch
was going to be a cross between
platforms mobile and console as a result
I do believe as an in gatoring
does have something to do with my
maybe this graphics card is actually
designed so that it will not excel in
mining thus giving gamers a good
alternative to super high-priced GPUs it
could also be designed specifically for
month' Nvidia probably makes a lot of
revenue and sales from GPU binary so I
don't think they would want to just cut
out a huge sum of their market as a
result I think that this new Nvidia term
may very well be a mining oriented GPU
so guys what do you think do you think
this will solve the problem of mining
and return existing GPUs to the old
price or do you think this won't do
anything except give miners more GPUs to
use for their setups make sure to
comment what you guys think I do read
all my comments and I am curious as to
what you guys think if you guys are
interested in the immediate earning then
make sure to check out my dedicated
video on that as well as Malta but
that's all I have for you guys this time
if you guys liked this video make sure
to drop a like on this video and smash
the subscribe button if you want to see
more videos just like this but that's
all I have for you guys just done
and until next video bye
[Music]